all right so this is a new mortal kombat
which isn't really it's not a new mortal
kombat
it's mortal kombat dlc slash mortal
kombat 11
has come to the ps5 not a ps4 version
for the ps5
but a ps5 version of mortal kombat 11
called mortal kombat 11 ultimate and
just to cover my bases again they sent
me a download code for the game
but then i realized that if you put in
your ps4 disk into your ps5 you get a
free ps5
upgrade for the game and all your
content it all transfers over not
as a ps4 version but the ps5 version in
which case me getting mortal kombat 11
ultimate for ps5 was no longer a full
price game
but it was a 15 dlc buy so i went ahead
and bought the dlc
gave the code to my friend and said here
you go happy gaming but in case
i just need to tell you they gave me a
code they did
i hope my friend's having fun with it
all right so base is covered so now we
talk about mortal kombat 11 ultimate
which for ps5
we're going to talk about some obvious
things there are to talk about better
load times the easy way to see
the fast slow times is when you
highlight the character and ps4 version
it was like highlight the character okay
taken a second all right there you go
there's the skin that you have for the
character ps5 version
much faster much more instantaneous to
see the version of the character you
actually have also load times into the
matches much faster much improved and
the 4k resolution for me an easy way to
see the higher resolution is in the
deadpool stage fatality
in the ps4 version the deadpool fatality
the steam coming off of the skeleton
it made it look really pixelated it was
like everything else around the skeleton
was high def but the skeleton through
the steam it just it's like it bumped
down to low res or something but on the
ps5 it doesn't do that it's much more
detailed it was an easy way for me to
see that i mean i export my videos in
1080 so i imagine this video is not
doing it justice but
trust me when you're there it's
noticeable but mk 11
ultimate is ultimately a new dlc pack
with three more characters no you don't
have a new
story that comes along with it like
mortal kombat aftermath so you don't get
a circular story
that ends up exactly where it started
leading basically exactly to [ __ ] all
well i mean if you're buying the 60
mk 11 ultimate game and you haven't
bought any of the mortal kombat 11 dlc
that came before it it does
come with all that dlc but if you've
kept up on the mortal kombat dlc that
has come out thus far
the new content you're gonna be rocking
is the addition of three new characters
one
rain which i guess is a fan favorite
i've never been a rain
person personally i don't know why you
know those characters in fighting games
you're like
people love them i just don't really
play as him the big win for me is molina
molina is back
also showing once again that when
characters die in a mortal kombat game
it doesn't matter they're not dead
they'll come back but i'm always
impressed with the fact that she
never plays exactly the same like mortal
kombat 9
x 11 she does play differently or combos
are
different though they have the same
flavor to them point is she's vicious
ferocious feral and brutal and i just
love her to death with her character in
the case of most mortal kombat
characters there's always one fatality i
prefer to the other yeah there's one
fatality where she turns into a spinning
ball of
sighs and burns through the person i
like the end pose she does but that
fatality as a whole doesn't hold a
candle to the one where she rips
open the opponent's abdomen reaches
up through their abdomen and the fingers
come out the face
she grips the face and she rips the face
down
through the guts and she's holding the
face
and they die see that there's something
there's showmanship there that one's
very creative that's what i love in my
fatalities brutal and creative and
that's just i love that one and this
time around we have sylvester stallone
as himself or as the johnny cage voice
announcer so eloquently puts it
john [ __ ] rambo you said it buddy
john rambo is in mortal kombat 11
voiced by sylvester stallone now it's
been apparent for a while ed boon the
crew at netherrealm they're big movie
nerds like the movie references in
mortal kombat
they've been around for a while and
sometimes they're really obvious
sometimes they're deep cut you're like
did they just
wow but it's exponentially grown as
they've had
more movie characters in mortal kombat
games the fact that they got sylvester
stallone is john rambo peter weller as
robocop
kari hiroyuki tagawa as shang tsung and
keith david is spawn
you feel the movie love there you can
tell they were like we have to get them
to voice them which also makes the fact
that arnold schwarzenegger does not
voice the terminator stick out like a
sore living tissue over metal
endoskeleton
thumb i mean it's impersonation it's not
a bad one you can tell
that's the voice they're going for but
it still sounds like an impersonation
you have been reprogrammed to protect
john connor from you
he will be terminated wait why am i the
bad guy it feels
different than the other characters who
are voiced
by the ones who played them in the
movies or voiced them in the animation
per spawn and actually adding this
little tidbit right now as this video
was exporting
i was about to upload it i just found
out that there's a mortal kombat movie
skin
pack for mortal kombat 11 featuring
bridget wilson
as sonia lyndon ashby as johnny cage
and christopher limber has raven then
this fight is now personal which is
pretty sweet it's a few extra bucks so i
would have liked that to have been a
part of the whole
15 dlc because now it's it's 20. but it
does speak to the fact that
like i said movie nerds and the intro
dialogues are so fun the fact that you
see
and hear john rambo reference shao khan
as shao kahn he says his name like
that's just that's next
level you just you're like john rambo is
immortal combat but if we're talking
intro dialogue
spawn and robocop amazing bad language
makes for bad feelings perfect
you're about to feel real bad
[ __ ]
too good the problem with mk 11 ultimate
on ps5 i don't know if it's a ps5 thing
or an mk11 ultimate thing that's just
across the board but it's definitely the
problem
i was having was the connectivity i mean
you can get into the towers of time just
fine you can do a casual versus match
just fine but getting into king of the
hill was a bit of a pain in the ass
though eventually i was able to do it
and so was my friend i was like hey can
you try these things out and he did
same as me he finally got into king of
the hill but in terms of towers of time
those group raid towers where you have
to team up with two other people
those suck you're either there waiting
for it to connect with a couple other
people
forever and it just never does it or you
find the connect with one other person
but not a second person so it's just two
people taking on the enemy not three i
was actually talking with this dude
online he and i teamed up we're like all
right i guess we'll two man rate it
and i guess if he's new to mortal kombat
11 because he was like i didn't know
there was supposed to be a third person
i thought it was just two i was like no
that big blank spot under us
that's for another human so yeah it
either just waits forever and connects
to nothing or connects to one other
person
i will say it's rare i won't say it
never happens because it did connect to
two other people
once tried many times because i wanted
to get that trophy where you have to
team up with two other people
finally connected to two other people
only happened once never happened before
hasn't happened since again i don't know
if it's an issue with the cross play
or just ps5 i had my friend test it out
he also has a ps5 and he had the same
problems i had so yeah there's that
that's a pain and it kind of compromises
the whole fundamental
element of mortal kombat and that talk
of trophies brings me to trophy talk in
which if you have the ps5 version of
mortal kombat 11
and you've gotten your platinum before
you've gotten all your trophies in the
ps4 version
you can now get all those trophies again
for the ps5 version new set of trophies
i mean same trophies
but you can just get them again and i
was curious about that all your content
transfers over from your ps4 version so
it was like
does it not know i did the story mode
does it not know how many chests i've
opened up and
it does give you a bit of a bump it
gives you a boost it helps you out
that's to say it apparently knows what
you have and haven't done so instead of
opening a couple hundred chests in the
crypt or whatever you had to do i just
had to open one and it was like great
here's your trophy for opening up all
those chests so sometimes you get a bump
like that where you just have to do one
thing instead of the whole group of
things
not for everything like i still had to
go through the classic tower with 10
characters still did that
still had to fight 50 online versus
matches luckily those did connect just
fine so i did that
also story mode all the chapters were
unlocked and marked as
completed so i just did the last chapter
in which you know liu kang you fight
cronica and it was like great
here you go thanks for doing half the
story also here's for doing 100 of the
story
good on you when all i did was just the
last chapter still have to do 100
consumables in the towers of times
it's just some things it helps you out
with some things it's like no you just
got to do that again point is getting a
plat after you've already gotten a plat
it's comparatively a walk in the park to
what you did before point is this mortal
kombat 11 ultimate packet
did what mortal kombat 11 packs have
always done for me
which is i get the pack i play it i play
all the new stuff
then i'm there for hours days and weeks
just
playing the rest of the stuff replaying
it doing towers of time
playing online or trying to play online
they've gotten a lot better at making
the costumes unique i was like yeah i
just i could
go for unlocking all of spawn's [ __ ]
because there are some characters where
you're like all right
kung lao's medallion i'm never gonna
lock in on that while the fight's going
down i'll never even know that it's a
different medallion whereas spawn his
different costumes
make him look fundamentally different
you can have some really cool unique
looking spawn belts in here
also rocking some new costumes that i
don't think were out before this might
have been but like i i
put mortal kombat 11 down for a while
until recently one is gotta love those
ultimate mortal kombat 3 lady ninja
skins to scarlet
am i right you clearly have a type it's
true
i do the big win for me the big surprise
was the fact that they gave that free
upgrade from ps4 to ps5 if you have the
ps4 version and in a world where i was
expecting to drop
60 bucks on three new characters but 60
bucks because it's the ps5 version so
there is that but i ended up only having
to drop
15 because of the free upgrade that
really feels like a win and it's
something they didn't have to do it was
really cool that they did
the rule of contrast there just keeps me
from bitching too much because there's
always that eye roll factor when it
comes to dlc for me or i'm like kind of
15 more bucks am i fine
but this is worth 15 bucks and that
upgrade that you get
between ps4 and ps5 versions instead of
being like
ah 15 more bucks i was just there going
oh wow saved 45.
awesome and yeah i'm having fun with
mortal kombat 11. again i thought we
were done
you know it's like mortal kombat 11's
kind of the gift it keeps on giving
for a price so it's the gift that you
keep buying the point is it's like oh
hey we're done with mortal kombat dlc
you know the past would speak to the
president the fact that we're done and
nope here's another
at this point i don't know if they're
gonna have another one but the roster is
actually a lot of fun it's a great
roster of characters and i'm personally
not ready for mortal kombat 11 to be
done and move on to the next thing that
netherrealm might do alright so mortal
kombat 11 ultimate have you played it
what do you think about it are you
having the connectivity issues that i'm
having are you enjoying the content most
importantly are you having fun with it
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
you